merci mon entraîneur a aussi souhaité
directement j'espère que monsieur mac on
verra mais soit en direct c'est quoi tes
souhaits s'étaient tous mes voeux pour
cette nouvelle année il la commence très
bien je voulais juste le dire que je
m'emmerde aussi ou là à d'accord c'est
comme ça ça des bahamas et démarre fort
je suis vacciné je les emmerde aussi à
d'accord
quand je vais y aller mais j'étais
perdue pour sa jeunesse cyril antonio
haut niveau à son niveau intellectuel
qui est très bas pour autoriser mais
vous lui en voulez de ce qu'il a dit
ignorer de ce qu'il a dit comment ben
moi je m'en veux énormément parce que
aujourd'hui il a réussi son coup et en
fait tout ce qui s'est passé mais je me
faisais tous tombés dans le piège il
vous a tous en fumée avec des mots le
mot emmerder ben pourquoi pourquoi il a
fait ça comme ça on regarde les termes
qu'il utilise pour qu'on ne parle pas de
son bilan plutôt sur les cinq hommes on
va en parler après s'il est candidat on
va en parler d'accord mais là en fait
c'est de l'enfumage complet qui nous
fait mais son bilan antonio juste pour
savoir au niveau du de la crise
sanitaire qu'est ce qu'il a fait de
moins bien que les autres pays mais il a
rien fait ils ont tous manqué à lancer à
leur tour ils ont tous menti nommé dès
le départ dès le départ ils savaient
très bien le virus qui arrivait on va
parvenir soit non non non non ça serait
bien s'il vous plaît merci pas dire
c'est donc je voulais juste vous dire on
sait très bien ce qu'il a fait il me
fait rêver là il veut mettre la lie de
mettre la faute de son incompétence sur
les gens qui ce n'est pas vrai si vous
n'êtes pas vacciné
il faut demander à mon médecin
maintenance et saas et le nouveau sport
des gens le demandent et à aux gens qui
sont là s'ils sont vaccinés mais ça ne
regarde que vous avec ses deux passes
vaccinale va être votée par un mot assez
règle et cyril jeu tu as is it rappelle
de moi chez nous il ya un an bien sûr de
venir ici mais demande à ricaner oui
quand j'ai dit le pass vaccinale va
passer tout le monde a rigolé
aujourd'hui les gens rigolent - tout ce
qui est les moutons aujourd'hui sont là
et on leur dit sauter par la fenêtre il
saute par la fenêtre il restera même une
personne en france qui ne sera pas
vacciner une seule ce jour là on dira
que c'est de sa faute il ya encore des
variants alors qu'elle est là cela me
gênait la solution en tonneaux la
solution les solutions à son très simple
à un moment donné y met son pass é mais
sa vaccination obligatoire et il assume
ce qui se passe derrière c'est pas plus
compliqué mais vu qu'il ne veut pas le
faire et c'est très bien tout ce qui se
passe les myocardite tout ça dans mon
entourage j'ai trois personnes je vais
pas les citer si c'est pas le but j'ai
trois personnes qui sont blessées une
canne jambes paralysées quand même qui
travaille dans un milieu quitte à
lialores est ce que c'est c'est
temporaire pour l'instant on ne sait pas
ce que ça fait c'est gad elmaleh
paralysie mais temporaire qui peuvent
être une mère est paralysé dans la demio
cardy temporaire est fixé mais ils ne
savent rien là dessus ça la protection
aussi